Hello, my name is Katherine Parker. I'm going to have a conversation
with Delvin Cruz for Visible Lives an Oral
History Project for the New York Public Library. It is January 21st
2015, and we are at...
.
Oh, it's January [laughs] January 22nd,
sorry...2015, and we are at
City College of New York in Manhattan.
.
So, Delvin, can you tell me...where you come from.
Originally born in Puerto Rico,
Ciales, small little town up in the country. One of the only towns that is
still, uh, countryside. No big malls have been built in there yet,
Thank God. I came to the United States at the age of 5 and
I grew up here in the United States, in the South Bronx.
And, um, can you tell me about, uh, growing up?
.
Growing up was a little difficult. Uh, My father has
visual problems, his father has visual problems.
His father's father has visual problems so it's a generic thing, um,but it's a generic
thing that not every one of your siblings gets it. My father has six kids and I'm the youngest
and I'm the only one who was born with a disability. It starts out with congenital cataracts,
but when a kid is born with cataracts, technically means that the kid is born blind
until his eyes fully developed, because a cataract completely covers the entire eye,
so the pupil doesn't have any.. any.. anything to see. It's obstructed.
So to the age of five I was completely born blind, I was blind. So
a lot of falls as you see. A lot of scrapes and bumps and marks as from-
from, when I, before I was five. Um, Living in the Bronx during
the 70s --  I was born in 1972, came here in 1977 -- raised in the Bronx
Bronx from '77 and on, it was very difficult at that time.
Disability Awareness was not there and, it's not like now, the
more people who are disabled are more accepted and there are more opportunities. Back then it was
none of that.
My first year in school, when I went to first grade, I was
thrown in school with everybody else, and there I was, could barely see the
blackboard, and on top of that, I didn't speak English, so I was only five years old
and, I remember being scared and terrified.
And, not because I didn't know anybody, but because I couldn't see that well
and I didn't understand what they were saying and what the teacher was saying.
It got a little better when I was transferred within a week to a
C.S. 90 which was one of the very first schools to start offering special
education for people with disabilities and got a little better there 'cause not only did they
use stuff for visually impaired- stuff written bigger but the teacher's assistant was Puerto Rican, too,
so, I was actually able to learn a little more better since somebody was able to guide me and tell me what they were
saying.
But, not being able to see and being treated different
as a child or even as a youth growing you don't want to be treated different you want to
be like everybody else. And at that age, you don't really realize your
limits, so you get hurt a lot, whether it be falling or tripping or bumping
into things until you realize what are your limits are. You get hurt a lot and
that was mostly my childhood and my preadolescence, discovering on my own, because I didn't want to be
different and I wanted to do what my other two brothers were doing and whatever my neighbors were doing, my
friends you know I want to do the same thing so I got hurt a lot learned how to ride a bike but I crashed a lot
and I got hurt a lot, but I finally learned how to do it, though.
So what, uh, you
Went then to Middle School? // Actually
Um.
It's weird, cause I never went to middle school. I went from elementary to high school
and the reason was, um, my first school in C.S. 90, they only kept
you to the 5th, grade but I don't know that if that time, they didn't have special education
didn't have inclusion classrooms. Where now students they were disabled there and they don't have
severe disability, like somebody like me, whos visually impairment. They can go and take classes with the
rest of the population and they receive the help they need but they are there with
everybody since they didn't have that they had in this
in this middle school in this elementary school in Manhattan. I don't remember the address
they had this little corner and the third floor of the classroom where there was two
rooms. One was for students there were
between the ages of 11 and 12 or 10 and 12 which was supposed to
be the 6th or 7th grade and then another rule once it was just
for the six grade, it was just for the lower. Once you got a to a certain age they moved it to your next room where you were there until
you were at the proper age to move to high school. So that I
never I never experienced what everybody's experience junior high school. When you start getting used to
going to different classroom you don't have one homeroom you don't have one you know I mean that was in the
entire day it was just like if it was just like regular elementary school the only difference is they taught us a little
more different school you know material you would learn in middle school high school
was the first school that I was actually in and a classroom with
everybody else.
And before that I guess that in having push I think it was because it was eighty seven.
I guess that's when they started what high school did
you go to one hundred and seventy eighth and Sheridan Avenue
in the Bronx. Did you know what your
siblings by the time I
finally went to high school.
All my brothers my besides my younger sister they were already in high school and upper
levels the next one next to me is it was two levels above me then the next one was
in Siena and twelfth grade and my two sisters by
then already my tortoises are very back drop out already. But what I was going there my brother
was going to complete high school and I was going to town.
And were you know like classes like everyone else.
My first semester I only have one class with everybody else
which was math and the other ones they
had I believe it was like just four teachers that taught one taught English
the other one taught reading and then I can and the other one was science
that was until my sophomore year that they started letting that they'll actually take classes where everybody
else like health education in the arts and all
the other classes.
During this time. How do you deal with your disability
.
Me really and I mean that's the negative
of having students just go straight just to special
education and mix them up with public school. What the general you know sort of having
inclusion is they have exclusion when you have inclusion you are allowed to
be in a classroom where everybody has to take in the same class you take on the same exams you get the
same learning at the same time when I went to high school the first
year or so it was more like you were in a room and to me it
felt like I was reading elementary books I was never a challenge at all
and because I was never challenged and I just never paid attention and I just never I didn't
care it was until I started doing my that I was moved to
inclusion where I was.
Challenge and I was able to put more attention and was more interested in it
in the one you know in the world and went
through.
Sophomore the first shuttle Yeah I was allowed one class myself me and I think they
allowed me to classes and it was until my second year in
junior that they gave me a little leeway and finally by my senior year I
refused to do it in class I wanted all my classes to be
with the general you know I don't want to say don't publish because there's not a person but with everybody else
and my thought was I wanted to go to college and I wanted to know if I can do college.
Because if you're in special education and you're not being challenge in you're not going to learn
what everybody says. Then you're going to have I'm going to be in a
disadvantage.
So even though I was advised not to go not to do it all that way. I
said I was going to and finally it was my decision because I had my mom write
a letter and say that if she didn't do it then moved me to another school.
They let me do it and there was something about it and I think a lot about
that is that was my most fruitful in my most productive semester was my senior
year in high out of the seven hundred and
something people they graduated
. My average finished at the top twenty students
and I was not bad at all and I was very impressed with that
.
How do you get fired in the classroom without being able to see my
teachers were understanding even though what I was not especially inclusion they were very
understanding in everything that I need to do is got to be enlarged
and big papers at the time the closed circuit T.V.'s was the big
monitor big I mean giant monitors.
And I never liked us because they help you see but they also give you a migraine headache
because you have to be so close to it and I don't know a lot of the technology that was back that was
horrible.
I'm so how what was
it really did you have with your siblings.
Love hate but I think that's very powerful. Yeah
I was one of the one my older brothers did. I
always wonder if they were in the streets ride their bikes. I wanted to do that too if they were in the park
climb his trees I want to do that too. The only problem
was my mom would let me do a lot of it because she was so worried that something would happen to me
. I guess you know that when I was playing my brother sometimes I'll just go into the things at least maybe
when I was talking a brothers hated me because they
didn't want to always be around me and when you're a kid you get that
impression. You know it's always know the grass is not always as brown as you think
it's always better. They were at the park and they were
playing a silly game where there everybody's telling different
stories what would you do if this happened. Meanwhile everybody would grab taking
the grasp on the grass and they were putting it and I don't know what was going on and next
thing I know everybody started on the grass and everything at me and my brothers and he was
in the in the circle he was playing around and.
I think he did it joking around just a little bit but when he did that everybody started turning
and when everybody started this one kid grabbed
me when he threw it at me I see my brother get up I
thought it was you see him but he actually got out but he turned on he grabbed the kid who actually threw the but I mean I started
beating him up and at that point I realized yes me they're
actually teachers they're there with me but they were given the space for me to do
my stuff because they knew my mother would let me do it.
So even though I thought they were getting they were always actually always there to help me out but they
gave me what my mom gave me they gave me the little leeway to let me get hurt
if I wanted to learn something so let alone on my own.
Well.
What can you tell me more about that getting fun
discovering things on your own.
Running a bike was for him for years.
You know when everybody learns to ride a bike their process is
learning how to balance the bike. Everybody's going to fall to the left or to the right
. I got the balance quick that was not my problem. I'm
stopping because that is the selling it comes a lot of I would bump into a
car or I would hit that sidewalk or a person so that was my
problem right there. And at first I got into a little out of the way it was because if I hit one of the
B.S.A. and when it's not your kid who's got the problems
everybody has a problem with what you know why you let his kid like this people get upset about it but
after a while I guess people just let me be in whenever they saw me on the bike they would just be
like the Red Sea the party people just a lot of the way it was kind of strange and weird
but I think what helped me the most was I am. The lighthouse over a fifty ninth Street
between Lexington and Park Avenue. I think they still have it. There's a program
that was set at a program where the people people who are visually impaired.
You go there and depending on your age group they pair you up with that group
and you're there for an entire Saturday and they teach you swimming
bowling. The new ceramic work
artwork that free time and when you get a little older like in
your in your twelve or thirteen in the mornings instead of being what everybody else in the
lighthouse you know playing games they take you to they had a case they
had an agenda but it was a few blocks away where you
go in there and he had trainers who help you learn how to use the
machines how to exercise but it was open to the general population the ages I
guess rented if they were they still had the regular members came in. So you had that right
there where one of the out of the week I wasn't legally
blind Why wasn't a different kid in the block or I was in a different kind in the house I
was there with everybody else who had the same problem. Some were actually more legally
blind. And the reason I think I like that the most because
me being able to see other people they had the same thing that I was going through kind
of helped me deal with the fact that I was in a room I was not the only one in the world
who was doing this because when you have a disability
sometimes and you start getting older you question why me why this is happening to me and you
think you're the only one. But going through that process and being around other kids that had it
helped me in two ways helped me realize that I was not alone
and I saw how other kids took that impairment disability and
kind of like threw in the towel and didn't care they want to learn anything just accepted
that they were different and there will never be able to do anything so I took that as a challenge to say that I'll
never want to be like those like that group and I want to be like those that I saw it I never wanted to be like
that so again in mind and I learn to do a few things and I use that as a
motivator to be more risk taker to do more daring things.
From elementary up through high school I had to take what we used to
call the cheese bus which is the yellow bug you know the school bus we call that the cheese
bus because at that time Lisa give American cheese for free to families low income
big block of yellow American cheese.
So the boss was a big a stickler the cheese but I had to take
it and when I was in high school I didn't want to take it from my mother she
wouldn't let me get off it I have my first day in high school I go on
to me that was very embarrassing. So my brother had to go to
Clayton High School and his high school was on the way to my high school
. So what we started doing was he planned it that I would plan
every day. Sneak out and pretend I lost a boss I missed the bus in the first few days that whole
part of way with him. He told my mother he would. What went to school but what would you I would
do is we just walk to the bus stop yelling across the Grand Congress which was at that time he looked like a
giant ST To me it was on one hundred fifty seven wall and Grant Congress we had across
that. But once we were across the street he would go
his own way with his friends and he would leave me there because he already had taught me how to get to school I'll take the one
bus get off the one hundred and seventy street on how to do just what one blocks and cross one
street and the school was there after the third week of
school. My mother gets a letter saying that since I am not using the
bus that they're going to remove me from the list and that's the first time she learned about it she
was angry but when my brother you know like to her that he's been working with me every
day and that I'm the one in finding and I know how to do it. She finally loved me and that was what I
actually think was the first time of my independence where I was able to go to school on my
own and I have to go out on a bus or anything.
What. Kind of what was
what was that like taking
taking public transportation.
Nothing weird.
When you used to a routine every day where somebody picks you
up and then you got it all right and I pick you up around seven seven o five
seven ten seven ten in the morning to go around and pick up all the kids
and you go to school and by the time the driver reaches the school it's like eight thirty eight
forty five. They're on a bus for over an hour because the bus driver just didn't pick up people in
New York in the Bronx he had to go to Manhattan and I guess T..
Oh look our arch with the bus was parked I guess it was close to my house because I
was always the first one to be picked up again on a bus and
you know one day you get there in less than ten minutes it was like a
different it was soul like free time because once you got there
you you had time to do other stuff you had time to go and have lunch and actually meet friends
and develop friends and when you go
to war when you go to a school and there's a lot of kids in your neighborhood or nearby they
take the same route and go to the same school and you go to the same bus every
day after a week or two you start talking and you become friends and you start you know
develop in this groups or cliques or whatever they want to call it.
And you start socialising and meeting more people that are not your it you know that or not with
your disability but since you're at high school already that I don't care
anymore you know it's I was pretty strange good at the same time
be in Azad the buzz where you have to sit in put a simple line and the
buses back them was not like the buses now you have the two seats and then another one behind two
more scenes and another one and it was straight seat in one so I kind of like the way the
trains are but not the one to decide the number four train the let's you know the six
train would be a better example. Well that just once I was all like that
. No matron to tell you to sit down to walk around
and it was I found I found that to
be fun.
Can you talk about you.
Growing. Like what do you do
you talk a little bit more about your parents.
My mom and my dad divorced before I was born
my dad is more visual impaired than I am I see better than he does.
Hi I don't need glasses to see around he has
glasses that are like Coke bottles. Bottom of coke bottles are like real thick and if you don't
you know that when he can't see at all. But he was a
history teacher in high school in Puerto Rico and he taught for thirty six
years and he's a genius My
father is a genius I feel he has AIDS and eidetic memory which is what most people call a
photographic memory. He
would have his students open the book.
And he will start reading the book. But he will start walking around the room as he's
reading because he already memorized it and the store has to catch him on an
errand then following along.
While I like my home and I think that was his technique to teach him to follow follow
and never caught him on a mistake because it would follow because they want they would they want to do with that
one they want to be that one student it would find him making a mistake that he said something it was not on the page
when he said something that was wrong and I never did and he is
just real smart.
My mother I think Elementary was the highest level she did she did
she got married I believe age of thirteen. Back at that time I guess that was the
norm here. Yeah kids don't kids got
married very young. Back then I think she got married in either
nine hundred sixty one or fifty nine I don't remember the exact year
but she got married just to get out of my grandma's house
come from the fashion family where they really
don't know how to raise people their race and the way they were raised and that's by
hitting them young then turning them into slaves. Given no
love.
Just a horrible way to grow up and they just can't pass it down
and that's the way that was I was taught as to what you were taught.
I'm glad my brothers and sisters didn't teach to teach their kids that way they broke the
cycle. At one
point I didn't think my mom loved me just
because the way she treated me different and everybody else now that
I'm older I understand it. She was worried about my disability and having a visual
impairment. He can't let you could go out running around in the street by a
car or something can happen I understand that at least now I do but
when I was growing up I just I just thought she was a she me.
I'm actually going to see my father now on vacation next week going to Puerto
Rico. He lived there he never came here.
My father.
He's awesome even though he didn't race me I
have a lot of respect for him for how much we accomplish would be less efficient than I
have in a country where he didn't have accommodations when he
went to school when he went to high school there was no such thing accommodations and he
succeeded not just being a teacher being an awesome teacher
has only negative was that he was a drunk and that's the reason he started teaching.
He stopped teaching. But other than that he he's very he
has. Thank God he hasn't drank in over twenty years now. He stopped drinking. He's very
respected in the time. Whenever I visit I say I look identical like my father
when he was young when he was my age when I was his age I mean that was so
they recognized and went whenever I'm visiting him.
If I'm walking anywhere people give me a lift and they start talking about my
father and the funny thing is it's the same people pick me up every time I go and they get older
and I guess since I'm not there all the time they forget become of the story and they repeat the same stories all over again
. But I enjoy it because it's like reruns you know are you can you go to
like listen to stories about your parents. People are proud to tell you about stuff they did.
What kind of stories.
Yeah. Next question
.
OK So your mom came to New York with
you and your siblings that your dad said I
told you when I was born in one thousand seventy two when my parents before I was born I was already
divorced my mother got a
boyfriend and then which is my younger sister's father and we came
out and by the age I was five so from maybe till I was
maybe six seven or eight months somewhere around there. My stepfather was the
one that was there living with two we were five till I was five then in one thousand
seventy seven he had his first daughter and he didn't want to raise my
sister in Puerto Rico. So they come as my mom and we came to the United States
that was in one thousand of them was my sisters or
me. So around September of one thousand seventy seven we came to New
York and he moved into the apartment been no
we moved into my aunts my mother's sisters my aunt's
apartment for a few months until we found the place it was
at one hundred fifty fifty or fifty six and Melrose Avenue.
Which is nothing the way it used to be like there is a lot of burned buildings at that
time and none of the buildings they were there at the time was there anymore the second buildings look nice
now for a few months we lived with my
aunt and my aunt already had three kids. Most are
self and it was only a two bedroom apartment it was pretty crowded. A church we met this
lady her name was loose and. She didn't know what she just
matter there and after like maybe a month of knowing her shopping our house and we were
able to move in with her and she showed my mom where to
get um she's the one who took my mom and told her to put me in special ed
and got her all the paperwork squared take me to school where they would help me I
took my mom so we can get Social Security and when they prove that I was
glad I got mean the commission for the Blind which was the last book in the light house
and with her I think we lived for one year and then we finally got our own apartment when we were living
along.
It's all problems. Rose by one hundred forty nine hundred
fifty fifty one run the whole neighborhood
and.
What did you say you mentioned biking or no. But
imagine that like the bike. What other things did you go around the
neighborhood with for fun.
Than what you see on the square. I grew up in
the greatest neighborhood in New York in the Bronx. Two
blocks away from the greatest New York in the
history of the sport I grew up two blocks away from Yankee Stadium. Yankee Stadium was
my background. Since we lived there
every weekend but in the summers when there was no school and there was honking we would go
to the games.
It was I think it was big for all six kids to go to the game
and my mom and my step father I think he spent less than fifteen dollars for everybody to go
. Probably even less than ten people was at that time. So we were able
to go there and whenever the NGO My mom sent me and my two brothers to the
game we would ride a bike all around the entire Yankee Stadium in the
parking lots they have a mortgage they just built
a few years ago maybe five years ago maybe a little less gateway more
that's a little further from the or Yankee Stadium it's where we
used to be the markets not to Hans point where they have all of the
vegetables all the fruit and they mass produce and sell it by
both people in the streets. It used to be there and it used to be also an
abandoned and abandoned train station
and we had after five or six o'clock when it's done it's just a fun place if
you're a kid to go play around just because you got it all subway station you
roll around in the stuff that you get away your parents don't see you you can get
away with things and they would throw away the
vegetables they didn't sell that were going bad they will promote side and work and don't like to grab
vegetables and throwing stuff and stuff like that.
Now each other all friends everybody was playing
instead of points Nobile the plate on Rotten Tomatoes or whatever and we just saw
saw from being out into song to go I want you to come because you always find
some good ones here.
We used to go there once. Once my mother discovered it did it threw away
food. That used to go there after his clothes and make up like
plant things banana carrying lettuce and
stuff that they know that was going to go bad the next day they knew that by the time the next day
came they would be able to sell so they would put it out and people come take it. Now they let it
run away. So we used to go there and I used to enjoy going there. It's
just fun and one time my mother was going and she didn't want me to go
from getting troll or something I don't remember what I know I'm not hard to get drugs she let me go because whenever
she goes you always take me with her because when she found out what we lived through
does throw things around and she found out that there was a railroad station
and next to it was the East River but there's no there was no law. No
Gates or fences or anything. So anybody could just walk right into the river and Foreman
and she discovered that she would let me go further so whenever I go it was on she went
and one time I think I don't know what I did You can let me know and I was so angry that I
actually literally punched and broke a window because I was angry that I was only I was able to
do to go and then I try to tell that somebody to a bawling not
realize and then if someone had broke all the glass would have been and so I think
kids do funny how you see seventy
three.
Maybe less not seven or eight yeah. Definite was over six because that was
an Gerard Adnan who lives in Girard Avenue hundred
and fifty seven for a few years and then moved to one block
up one hundred fifty seven and walked in and there we lived two I think in one thousand nine
hundred sixty one nine hundred eighty seven
. One time in that neighborhood.
Very dangerous neighborhood to this at this point
. This was before Rudy Giuliani actually
made the city especially the bronze a place where even tourists can come and visit
and where I lived. Only that they only that they said they were Yankee
games. Would you see a lot of police officers and it was just to protect the people
again when there was no games. You barely see a cop. I
remember when I was twelve years old they shot this guy
right in the middle of my building entrance line
. That guy was there for over six hours
before the first cop came but I don't
blame this one cop was chasing I think it was a rookie who
was chasing this does this person a drug dealer or whatever.
And chase him to the roof and next thing you know the cops
find out of the room.
Yes it was very dangerous and since cops didn't feel safe they wouldn't go
no matter what lived on the first floor.
Whenever there was a gunshot the first team. Our stepfather taught us to do
. Jump you know tell yourself to the ground and then
crow it was like this big hole we between the two rooms crawl on which were the
hallways and you stay there. So if a bullet goes through the window doesn't
hit one of us because a little five year old girl she was in a room
playing doll and a bullet went through of your own apartment
and live there for so long that gunshots
probably like three times a day. You got your tongue itself in the
ground in one thousand you know the one
I graduated from high school and applied to
. College. But at this time I was
entering my Rebel stage where I didn't want to live with my mom anymore. I felt like I could live on my
own and my only way to do that was to go to college
so I found the college that I can go to that was the furthest the longest farthest
away. I'm going to post miss college
postman's college is next to a town called Saranac Lake
.
And that probably town is now familiar. That town is next
to another town that is familiar Lake Placid which
is forty five minutes from the Montreal border in Canada
. It's roughly four hundred something miles
and the only way to get there was at around the
Trailways because it's in the Adirondacks and there's one and only one bus goes there daily
. The bus leaves here in the morning at nine
and he gets there a little close to eight thirty at night because he does a
lot of stops and it stops in Albany for a while. Steps in Syracuse for a while and he just
does it well is dropping but it drops you off there and it's in the middle of
nowhere and.
I went to this school and it's country or country
Saranac Lake is eighteen miles away from plasmas college plasmas college is in a
little town of Posner's with a population of less than five hundred people.
The closest store convenience store to the school
was five miles away and that was only open at certain times if you wanted to
go to a restaurant or you want to go to a supermarket you have
to go to the Saranac Lake which is eighteen miles away which I love riding my back so I wrote that
bike every day eighteen miles back in eighty miles back
but the reason I'm going to this story is I was accepted into plus his college degree
program which is the Higher Education Opportunity program a G.O.P. which I think now
it's got a different name and the way they did
their program was they put the students in for a month
for part of June not part of July and most of June
July and most of August and they let you take it remedial classes and then let you take the
class so you can get used to the you know the college situation because they're all freshman's and most
of the people going there are minorities or people who are disadvantaged
and. You're on the weekends we go we go on different
retreats whether it be a hike a mountain couldn't write a
farmer's market just one weekend they had to firemen's convention in
Tupper Lake and this is a convention for a whole bunch of firemen's where they do a
whole bunch of stuff that people here in the Bronx go look at it or even in the ACBL. What these
people do and carving words into frames what would happen with the chainsaws
breaks and doing a whole bunch of weird stuff but the reason of my story is I was at McDonald's
on line to get food and I was
the only minority. The only Hispanic in the world in the town of what
we call Hicks people from the locals you know with a
flannel shirt or beard and you.
Know managed to know all black people here they want to match their shoes to their parents
or their shared this often is that there's no mash at all nothing.
And I'm online winning each winter because I can
play something Ronald McDonald was with a whole bunch of kids
.
And they're going to lose and they do want to do one of those helium
tanks and Latin pop
briefing was the first thing I did.
I threw myself to the ground just yet. I thought it was a gotcha.
When I'm in the government my my friend real speedy because that's what they call me because I was always in a rush to go in
my you know when I looked I was so I'm biased you got up and left.
And I told him I thought it was a gut check.
That's my money here but it's going to Utah he's up to the ground and I
threw myself on the ground like I'm such a reflex Yeah it's like why
am I the only wonderful on the one hand there isn't my first time and it was visible when I got some hours I got
it I got up and that I should have because nobody knew what nobody knew me there.
Yeah you
know more about being at college. But
yeah it's nice by the way I'm going to
need a copy of this.
Oh totally. I'm a creative writing major and I graduated last semester and
I did a few memoirs that some of my did about my childhood but
all of this at a time when you know I could not remember but I mean those stories
and I'm going to have to live mine.
My memoirs in college you know
my first weird experience I got to the
different reads We went to High St Regis mountain
and I've never hiked the mountain in the city
is going to go into the middle of the woods just to walk in the woods to climb all the way to the top
with there's nothing to have to call all the way back down it
doesn't make sense to somebody who lives in the city.
Jim Tucker was the name of the director of the of the G.O.P. program and
he comes up to me the day before we were going and he goes
hiking amount today do you have a proper shoe too
high.
I'm like yeah I know what he was talking I know he was asking if I had hiking boots.
I had a high top sneakers feline which was red
velvet and I supposed to get wet. And that's what I
took. To go hiking with. I'm hiking
and one thing you don't know if you are not from that area and you know high
mountain and if you need it in rain the day before
and it rained three days before there is hide
and what not.
The entire trails are silent and
mean by this point there
is no one around me and is because I tell them
.
I was talking like a New Yorker. F. this F. that anything is bugged. You
know the way New York was rude in foul language
so they don't want to hear it so that everybody walked on their employees
.
So. I need to know somebody to be there is watch your step of this or I'm
walking and I want to put my stuff I want to go
over a piece of tree that was on the ground so I want to go
over it. When I stepped on it it was completely self mine.
My only when all the way to my knees in mud
. Those red light red feel like sneakers I told you about we're not red no longer
so I took my foot out and I saw that I was screaming and
cursing like there was no time like where's my counselor thought
that's often happened to me so he came back and see what was going on when he saw that it was my
sneakers and he looked at me he goes I thought you said you have proper attire and he
just kept walking away. Next day he bought me a pair of boots
says here next time you go using I one can no one once
and I was on my own. I enjoyed going canoeing
for some reason I enjoyed the quietness. It took me a
little while because it's kind of we when you live in New York taxis
guns fired on arms fire drugs police and ambulance
and in my blood gunshots everything so much noise you can't hear yourself think. When I
was there it's like high heat. Once five o'clock came
I could actually hear the antics and it reminded me when I read this in Puerto Rico.
So I kind of enjoyed it and that was like my sanctuary so I would go in the canoe and go out
. And I would go in the middle the first time I went to my When I went to the middle and I just
you know put the pedal down and just lay down and relax
on that which is let the crew do it something if you want to meet
underneath a big tree and I guess I go this is cool is kind of sunny and I think I'll stay here for a
little while in the middle of July up in Iraq in
July they have these flies to be called black flies at The
Ohio. They do you like there's no
tomorrow and their sting hurts for a while I
had a big flock of black flies climbing over me when I woke up all of
them. Oh my God I was so horrible but I had in mind
you know it's my mind that at that time but the other the experience you learn
from being in there.
My first semester after that summer I was in the middle of diverse
one of my roommates and a friend was from Orange County New York
. The other one was from Long Island. The other one was from Buffalo New
York and one was from Japan.
There were fun fun guys we got in we got over and rode together and did a lot of wild
and crazy stuff the first time I got drunk.
It was the weirdest thing in the world. I don't know
I don't have a big astigmatism I said I used to have a few years ago
I had one might let my eyes corrected in two thousand and
seven. They did the last surgery so I don't have that much severe stigmatise they
still move around but I had it even worse. But when I first got drunk I
discovered that my eyes straightened out
one hundred percent straight up and I was able to see better. Like this is my
weakest of my week I and
I thought that that was a cool thing so I decided to get drunk again and get drunk again
. After a while you know that's all you do. Especially when the live upstate New
York and it's winter from September to probably the first week of June
when I flunked out of school my first semester that O F's
. Well yeah I don't want to blame the teachers I don't
want to blame my disability I didn't know what to do with my
freedom. I was like a spring that was kept in a jar and when I
was finally opened it was so much compression I just went nuts went crazy.
I went to school from ninety one to one thousand
ninety eight and all I got out of it was just an Associates.
I went back to college in two thousand and eleven.
I would apply to leave in college when they told me that my G.P.A. was below
it so I needed to improve my grades be allowed. So my plan was just to go to
Bronx community college for one semester and hopefully get a great job. My first semester I got all eight
courses and I thought it was a fluke so much I will take one more
semester and I got another eight or a pass' after my
second semester so that all I mean it was just to classes to get a degree in early childhood
education side but they might as well stay there. So I
stayed there and I got a pluses through the entire three semesters
. By the time I graduated I I was graduating and I
applied this time I decided to put City College first. Even though I didn't think I was going to get accepted
with my G.P.A. from the Bronx community they accepted me right away and I came here
in the fall of two thousand and twelve and just graduated last semester.
Would a three point seven seven nine G.P.A..
There's all the stories in college when I can't go through life because the public is going to
listen to it. Some of my future employers might listen to have you know this
crazy
those who went to college who had to drive away to go to college they know one of them
going to be you know I think that's the true excuse a college you got to learn to fold
.
You know to get up and you experience prepares you for the real world I think
in a small way.
Definitely And that's true.
So what do you do in between going to
college in the Adirondacks and then going to college
.
In one thousand nine hundred eighty. Was when I graduated from
Clayton community college and when I finally got my associates
and what did you and sorry I don't mean you know what did you get yourself
green as just liberal arts liberal studies.
And the only reason I didn't do that was because I flunked out of the Sony Sony POS and which is the school
I went to the poster's college because when I went to post-college I would ask
my I did my major was clean their yards and I wanted to be a
chef when I went to take the classes and I discovered that they don't teach
you how to cook.
They used to teach you how to make the preparations look good and
you know the secrets of the business management so they don't teach you how
to cook they don't care if your food tastes good so is your preparation looks good you get a grade
.
So once I discover that I don't really want to waste my time doing that so I just I just finished two years
important colleges because I like the place and I mean I was amazed to leaf
.
I remember one time I was on my fridge This was my first semester later on when I took my first chef
class and we were supposed to do.
Cut cut potatoes and they're teaching us how to do some type of BRAF or consummate I
don't know what it was and because of that they do teach you how to make
consummate a sauce and Sue's but they don't teach you any of those nice fancy recipes out of created you know
it was not what I was looking for but I was cut and material in my carrots.
A conversation with my next door with the person next to me and I'm not looking out
for the people who are not seeing a lot of looking at what I'm cooking. My head is turned to the left side
and I'm talking and I'm just cut and cut and cut and I was stunned.
Chef comes next to me ghost over can you please look at
what you're cutting you got me nervous you're gonna cut your fingers off because you're not
paying attention and I go look at him like Professor what's the
difference if I look at it I'm still not seeing one.
But he just laughed and it was true if I don't see what I'm bored let's
look into the person next to me. I cut it by feeling to myself I feel when I'm doing
stuff and I kind of learned a trick where you kind of put you give
him you Ben you're NOT course then you let the my rest on you
and your nails
. So if you do going to get cut what's going to get thing is you're now and you've got to feel it so you know
you've got to close and I actually thank God I never cut
myself with a knife when I was doing all that stuff.
But I want to post in college and I joined a fraternity in one thousand
spring one nine hundred ninety four and got really interesting.
Well this is the reason I joined a fraternity I don't think I'll ever do that is because
after coming to college in one thousand ninety one. And then
transfer him to Sunny Hostin Potsdamer your Which is next to
Plattsburgh in the one nine hundred ninety three
I met my first Puerto
Rican friend or Hispanic friend in general but it was
Puerto Rican and we hit it off pretty well we both were from
New York we're both Puerto Rican and we both enjoy the Yankees.
When I learned he was in a fraternity he invited me to all the parties I used to go and hang out
all the time that I'm like you know what I'm asking you to join your thousand pledge a fraternity
so I pledge that in I was and this party from ninety eight
I can see is that from spring one nine hundred ninety four to one thousand
nine hundred eighty my it's a blur. It's a blur and
I remember my heart. Yes so I had to go to another school to
say they gave me the probations and after that they go sorry you're out
. So I'm I am I finally got the associates and after
ninety ninety eight I stayed in class because that's what Clinton was. Community colleges in Plattsburgh New
York found a roommate who was nice and he got me a job at a restaurant as a
as a dishwasher and I started working there and
I'm doing the dishes that's my job there are just a dishwasher nothing else.
This guy used to be the head chef here he went to college
.
And he.
So I was talking about plus missile I mentioned that I was on the placement.
We start talking about the professors there and how everything nice
was there for the restaurant walked by and they were
best friends. So he's telling you believe Scotland
Plus most college tour and you can wash dishes and have
a tall American Graduate. We never asked me. All he was talking
this was my first day at the job
. None of my first is this is the first weekend so is like my third day
at work. After the third day I work the manager calls me over to the to the
bar loose inhibit majoring in English so you have to close my eyes to a Mac.
Yeah it was a good school. I like the professor that he was you know a lot.
Now we see a talent washing dishes he promoted me about their day to our line cook and
when I was going to tell him on was letting go to school for a common area I was going to do that
got me a raise and a promotion.
Answer was yes and they can tell you it's in Plattsburgh
OK yeah it's a seafood restaurant and season one they only join the summer
because the lake freezes it's right in the marina so all the people with the boat
syllables it's the big thing in that corner.
Right here is a nice restaurant. I moved back to New York in two
thousand.
And winter of two thousand and one story and
got my life straight and in two thousand and three stop drinking anything
else that bad habits that I acquired in college and in my fraternity
started going to church for no reason I didn't hit rock bottom only five most people all the
fun went to church because he was a rock bottom I was raised in church. Russell look at race and
Pentecostal one day I just got tired of where my life was headed so I
just decided you know what I need to go back and I just went to church two thousand and three I met my
wife got married. I'm still married.
Can you talk more about how you met your wife.
Do you have to leave by five.
I don't finish what I started over there. I got at least an
hour of work over there. But anyway I mean my wife a church
OK. She didn't want anything to do with me.
According to her I was a loud person.
I can't believe I mean you can blame me I was a drummer. Drummers are
loud. We're used to those things and we're almost there. We gotta speak louder
so I started joking around with her because her last name was
Cruz my last name is crude. So joking around you know we get married you don't
have to change your name. Suddenly she didn't want to have anything to do
with me she's five years older than me like now going to
sleep. I get mad when a little kid consider me to be a mature
kid. She used to tell me all the stories on how anything she
wanted she would pray to God and God always answered the prayers
that no matter what she wanted that God answered our prayers. So she talked so much
about that that one day when I turned thirty years old.
I was praying the custom of praying every night for you go to bed when you wake up. I was praying
and I was kind of dirty and single not married
.
Nothing so I was kind of I started crying and God You know
I need to get married before I turned thirty one and I was like you know what
that I don't want to waste my time of this girl if she doesn't want to be
with me. But if this is the girl that you have for me I want you to change her
heart and make fun of me. Three months later we got married
we still married.
I guess God does answer. Craig so she's like
I don't understand how we got married like a year later she goes how we got married I HATE
MY don't we always tell God Anything you ask me gives you've got to
change your heart and make you fall in love with me. So it's your fault so whenever something goes wrong she's
angry with you having cheer for you gave me the secret I had to
cut this.
So I'm going to finish with something if you have any other questions for that.
I just applied to the New York City teachers fellowship and I'm hopeful hoping hoping that I get
accepted I want to be a teacher in the city of New York dealing with special education
kids. I want to be able to help those young kids
so that I struggled what I struggled because I went through the system and
I don't like that way.
Let's just put it this way to have a kid.
I wouldn't trust them in the same teachers that taught me I was at a huge disadvantage when I
went to college. They were talking about books that I've never heard before
and there are books that every kid has reading in high school. Catarina right.
Those you know the basic books I didn't read any of those books.
And they I don't know if it's still the same attitude because I don't I don't go to public
school and I don't want to put the added to when I was growing up was just call them their into
their of age and just move them on. So she's more will you got a malakas
you turn your age and you got to move on and I don't think that's fair to students
who really want to learn and really want to make something with their life. I want them to see
that there is hope even if you're disabled you can still become something in life
.
Thank you so much to all of them. It's a pleasure hearing your story and
speaking with you wish we had more time I said
maybe we can pick this up some other time if you like. Yeah maybe
.
OK.